I guess what I think veganism is I went
to vegans for dummies I don't know much
about veganism but what I do know
starting tomorrow
the four of us will be vegans for the
next 30 days I don't feel good about
being on a vegan diet well no way we're
gonna do a tofu I would probably suckle
directly from a cow's teat my diet now
is like whatever I don't know what I'm
gonna do without cheese yeah I have some
concerns wine my sanity I just hate the
thought of like restricting what I eat
or doing this for a month because we
actually do want to really have the time
to take this seriously and learn about
what it means to be a vegan I want to
try a vegan diet maybe because that's
that's the way of the future I feel like
this will be a good cleanse for my body
to say at the end of this that I will go
vegan very slim chances however maybe I
come out of this and get in the habit of
cooking more in just doing better things
to my body in general it's day one I've
already cheated alright so she just
recorded me saying I'm eating this I've
been eating salad all day we are gonna
meet with a nutritionist and get some
advice because none of us know how to
pee could be I work out a lot and I'm
really concerned about protein
you actually don't have to worry too
much about it because a lot of the
grains and the plant-based foods that
you're eating that replace the protein
so the Greens the legumes the beans
those foods have a lot of protein in
them there anything vegan that's
delicious yeah there's tons of stuff
it's like it's like washing like
avocados are delicious I like roast
fruits and vegetables so hey thank you
so much look this has been very very you
nating I'm no longer happy when I
hungry and that's kind of sad it's
really sad yeah a little hope there's
free hot dogs at work
we had the vegan hot dog we're just
gonna get chili dog must be nice not
afforded that luxury because BuzzFeed is
helping on punishing me for no reason
we're about two weeks into being vegan
and I feel pretty much the same I think
I'm just a tired person to begin with so
any other additional tiredness just kind
of blends in it's definitely been like a
roller coaster both like mentally and
physically over the past couple of days
I've been like pushing myself to go out
to like different vegan restaurants and
try like a bunch of like awesome vegan
cuisine I've actually started paying a
lot more attention to what I eat and I
be tending a lot more fresh veggies and
I've been eating a lot more varied foods
I feel really tired all the time I'm
constantly tired and I think it's
because my body is lacking protein again
it wasn't my fault
this guy got me so we realized on day
one as Vergara holds a cream cheese
bagel in his hand that people were just
gonna cheat willy-nilly if we didn't
have some kind of rule going on so now
we have a rule where if you cheat you
get a punishment long story short
Justin tan had a turkey vegan sandwich
or what he thought was a turkey vegan
sandwich gave it to me was like well you
got taste his vegan sandwich it's pretty
good you don't be this sandwiches vegan
from the green vegan truck as part of
Ryan's punishment we got him a veggie
burger and Justin will be eating his
favorite meal which happens to be four
by four in it
yo freakin kidding me
but - wait are you seeing how to see man
you have a nice tasty veggie burger
waiting for you yeah I wanna take my
first bite here mmm you throw this my
script check today and have none of it
ice cream Brentwood Brett boy at death
I'm in the last week of veganism and I
feel ready for a burger in the beginning
I was using a lot of fake meat to
replace real meat and it was actually
making me feel a lot worse after that I
decided to start eating more natural
foods so more fruits more veggies and I
started to feel a lot better I do think
it's possible to be a meat-eater and to
use dairy without contributing to you
know sort of cool practices like there
are farms that treat their animals
ethically and the last week of this we
are going to our co-worker Caroline's
house where she's gonna cook us my vegan
meal that's actually good she's a vegan
expert so I'll have a chance to eat
something that's not beans and rice
I'm vegan I'm vegetarian but an
excellent vegan chef I've got a weeks
ago I was talking to
Disha and Ryan about what they were
eating and it was making me very sad so
I wanted to show them what actual
leaving food can be like we're gonna do
yellow curry we're gonna do some large
and then sweet sticky rice coconut and
mango like we're the kids helping at it
Thanksgiving dinner whenever somebody's
Milton about your major life choices
like like food you're going to eat the
thing that you really define your kosher
vibe that can be really off-putting to a
lot of people but I think if you show it
like this then you can make delicious
food there's not a deprivation I think
that's much more encouraging to people
to meet a healthier life maybe even
lifestyle that is very necessary and
changing environment I'm no longer vegan
it's been one week since our experiment
ended I feel pretty good it definitely
had its highs and lows but overall I
would say being a vegan wasn't terrible
going into this I didn't really know
what being vegan was about as far as
like why people do it and now I
understand why it's yep all the stuff
that we do to get the meat that we do
reintroducing meat and dairy into my
diet wasn't like the mind-blowing thing
that I thought was going to be just like
oh yeah it's just food you know maybe
I'll find some more ethically raised
meat Chipotle serves ethically raised
meat your diet is often tied very
closely to your identity in your culture
and I think huge diet changes can be
really difficult to adopt not just on
like a superficial taste level but also
on like an emotional and a cultural
level I sort of have a greater
appreciation for what goes into my food
and what goes into my body and just very
appreciative of the fact that like being
vegan has helped me feel good when
eating I think that my whole life I've
always struggled with like food and
making sure I'm eating right and and you
know trying to be a certain size like
you just learn how to eat right that
feeling of feeling good feels so much
better than like trying to be a certain
size
you